now that you do have a mirror ball do
you have more say in who your partner is
season wish that was okay Shauna Burgess
fresh off for Dancing with the Stars
season 27 win you are a professional
dancer on Dancing with the Stars you
look amazing
do you ever look in the mirror and have
those well I wish I could tweak this one
little part or maybe exercise and dance
isn't enough always
I used to yes I used to have a lot of
buddy insecurities and buddy just mafia
really and it comes from being in the
dance industry and all the way back from
when I was 15 but I've gone through my
journey of loving my buddy and I love my
curbs and my muscles and my everything
so I want to maintain her and take care
of her as much as I possibly can
and that's why she's taking Edie along
for her first ever truthful tidy by
cutie recession the green light
signifies that they're about starting
and warming up it's a non-invasive
treatment that uses heat to eliminate
fat cells we only want the area we're
treated this is the kind of a little
sticky rubber that holds those these in
place it feels like a heating pad it's a
soothing warmth for Sharna this
15-minute procedure is about toning
though I am 33 that is still obviously
very very young but I think that it
could do just in the lower abdominal
area the one that's really really hard
to target how long do the results last
for so technically the results are
permanent because the energy is causing
an inflammation that causes a permanent
change in the body why is this a great
option and treatment to sort of start
the new year off well everyone's gonna
be cheating over the holidays that
pumpkin pie exactly but January to March
typically I want people are wanting to
do everything they can to look great for
the summer months
so how are you feeling not so awesome
but I like how good of rehearsals I
could get on a plane
[Music]